et pour en parler avec nous sur ce
plateau jean célestin edjangué
journaliste et essayiste auteur
notamment de ce livre kamerun un volcan
en sommeil bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invité sur lesquels on réalise
donc aujourd'hui leurs députés et leurs
conseillers municipaux
quels sont les enjeux de ces élections
d'abord merci le maquillage ou aux deux
plateaux
et ce sont des élections qui sont vos
dires emprunt de plusieurs enjeux il ya
bien sûr l'enjeu le plus immédiat qui
est signe de la sécurité
ce comment faire aller voter les gens
quand l'ensemble du territoire national
n'est pas complètement sécurisé est liée
à cet enjeu de la sécurisation est à
l'enjeu de la participation puisque
quand on peut pas aller voter on peut on
pas participé c'est une logique mais
au-delà de tout cela je pense qu'il ya
un enjeu qui encore supérieure si j'ose
dire c'est celui de retrouver un peu un
semblant d'unité nationale voilà un pays
qui a donné pendant trente ans
maintenant on va dire l'image des havres
de paix jusqu'à ce que on se rend compte
depuis deux trois ans maintenant quelque
chose qui va pas dans les régions du
nord-ouest et du sud-ouest
cette situation que j'étais non ce
depuis les années 2010 en espèces dans
ces régions il ya en amont il ya des dd
des éléments séparatistes qui demande la
partition du pays puisqu'il veut une
autonomie et une gouvernance partiel
total de cette partie du cameroun et ils
n'entendent pas continuer à rester sous
le joug du régime de yaoundé qui depuis
plus de 30 ans maintenant a quand même
donné l'impression d'avoir oublié un peu
le ddc cette partie du territoire
camerounais parti à anglophones du pays
et à cela s'ajoute évidemment les
attaques du groupe djihadiste boko haram
mayer dans le thé exactement à boko
haram c'est pas dans le nord ouest sud
ouest
c'est dans le nord du pays et quand on
prend l'ensemble des attaques du nord le
boko haram et celle du nord-ouest et du
sud-ouest
les chiffres les plus récents parlent de
plus de 3000 morts et déplacé en
quelques mois on va dire c'est c'est
énorme pour un pays comme le cameroun
qui compte à peine de 23 24 millions
d'habitants et tout cela constitue
évidemment donc l'enjeu sécuritaire de
ce scrutin café électorale un scrutin
que certains disent joué d'avancé
pour quelles raisons alors on dit qu'il
est joué d'avancé parce qu'effectivement
le code électoral ne permet pas à
l'opposition actuelle d'espérer
renverser la tendance
ils vont aller choisir sur les sièges
qui restent à pourvoir
et à peine 140 sièges et le parti au
pouvoir détient déjà la majorité absolue
à l'assemblée nationale et comme de
surcroît le mouvement
de la renaissance du camion couleurs
descendent du car audio du moscato qui
est arrivé deuxième à l'élection
présidentielle 2010 8,1 des reprises en
dix ans selon voir appelé à boycotter
deux parties ont fait appel également à
boycotter donc il ya fort à craindre que
la participation ne soit pas très très
heureux mais déjà pour la présidentielle
2018 on avait observé dans les régions
du nord-ouest où est ce que l'ensemble
des participants
c'est du régions-là avoisiner à peine
20% 15% je crois dans le nord-ouest et
5% du sud-ouest et c'est une bonne
stratégie pour le parti pour les partis
d'opposition notamment celui puisque
vous le souhaitiez de maurice comme ça
c'est une bonne stratégie que d'appeler
au boycott que de ne pas présenter de
candidat
alors on peut on peut dire que tu ne
penses stratégique
c'est peut-être pas la meilleure des
choses à faire mais en même temps sur le
plan politique ce parti qui n'a de cesse
que de contester y compris des résultats
des présidentielles s'il va voter alors
qu'en même temps de demander à ce que le
code électoral soit changé c'est donner
caution ccc acepté en fait un jeu
politique qui n'est pas en sa faveur et
donc on peut comprendre qu'ils appellent
à boycotter mais en même temps la peau
de la chaise vide n'est jamais la bonne
parce que si vous voulez être représenté
il faut aller aux urnes
si vous n'allez pas au jeu n'a aucune
chance et des tribus alors ok monde 75 %
des habitants ont moins de 35 ans ils
n'ont connu qu'un seul président paul
biya 86 ans dont trente sept passés au
pouvoir aucun parti d'opposition n'est
assez solides pour lui faire face
c'est compliqué le point de l'opposition
c'est quoi je l'observé mois
particulièrement en 2004
c'est que l'opposition camerounaise a du
mal à former une union
chacun joue pour sa propre chapelle ou
sans son sur son propre ego et
effectivement quand il ya des divisions
ça fait toujours le jeu du parti au
pouvoir c'est pour ça que l'opposition
raille le joug l'opposition camerounaise
investir d'autres pays d'ailleurs aura
compris qu'il faut se mettre tous
derrière un seul candidat lui apporté
son suffrage peut-être que les choses
changeront merci beaucoup pour votre
regard sur ces élections législatives
si pâle qui se joue aujourd'hui les
camerounais sont appelés aux urnes
merci jean célestin et jean je rappelle
que vous êtes journaliste essayiste et
auteur de ce livre notamment cameroun
dans sa merci beaucoup ce film aussi à
vous